did you see the clip that uh Crooklyn
from Crooklyn on twitter put up of the
owner of bare-knuckle boxing saying that
a fighter didn't fight hard enough yeah
I saw that yeah I and he was proud of
he's like this is the way we do it see
if you can find her tweet yeah this is
the way we do it this wicked hey yeah
like that was ridiculous I'm just gonna
dock a guy's pay yeah took 50% of his
money because it didn't meet there cuz
it didn't meet his standards yeah I just
a one when he said did the crouch air
that's something so I hope not I'd hate
to see that some of the crowd get your
felt man who sees on coke look at him
who's evil look I see you guys having
fun the night make some noise but the
whole Fighting Championship is a brand
new sport and a brand new company and
we're here for action and we want action
and we demand action from the fighters
mmm the man didn't get accident that
last fight cause rusty Crowder wanted to
run therefore he's given half this purse
for Reggie Barnett
make some noise Belov see this is how we
do it at bare-knuckle you fight or you
don't get paid
[Music]
that's not good it's not good that he
thinks the zombie prophet wrote this
can't be legal
he would see what Steffi Hayes wrote
Crooklyn Mme wonder how that works she
wrote what the actual fuck is this
hillbilly hosted yeah I concur what in
the actual fuck is that hillbilly
bullshit now I'm probably stood dock
right the yellow card was yellow card as
a penalty for being boring most don't
work yeah and sometimes irresponsibly
well I I've watched some of those yellow
cards make you crazy yeah you crazy
take that back yeah yeah yeah you gave
the guy a yellow car he can't fight any
harder yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we can't
engage he's gonna get lit up these this
moments we have to try to figure out
what the fuck to do you're on the
outside you're trying to figure out how
to get in right right now and you're
getting lit and then the referee is I
can't fight fighting like but in Asia
that some of they like some of them are
I used to work a lot at this Korean show
and they change their figuring out their
style but man when I first got to there
like um so there's a yellow card any
backward step a back step any back step
you should want to give it yellow cards
like lyoto machida would never make
anybody it's awesome saying I don't know
if I can do with that I don't think
that's I mean you invited me over here
for a reason I'm I'm just gonna do what
I do and hope you bring me back but I
don't know if I can do that yeah yeah do
do you ever go to a place and the
Commission's or a promoter will tell you
hey fights go to the ground I want you
to give it just a couple of seconds and
stand them up I go places and people
tell me what to do all the time really
and I'm not gonna do it at the end of
the day no one's gonna know that you
told me to do it it's gonna be me doing
it 100% yeah so I'm gonna yeah I can't I
can't
yeah basically so glad you just said it
that way too because that's that's
people need to get that in their head
because I know that sometimes people do
get affected by whether they want to
please a promoter or please a crowd or
and they're not doing the right thing
it's such a trans responsibility yeah
you're gonna but you're the one who's
gonna be for some of those choices you
know those
choices that they made they're making
those choices with your name yeah yeah
yeah I'd like the back step key Kevin
Johnson answering the guy but this is a
tweet from that bare-knuckle FC okay
Kevin Johnson no money was taken from
any fighters that statement did exactly
what is supposed to what was supposed
they didn't say to supposed and lit a
fire under every single fighters ass
from that point on giving you one of the
greatest fights you'll ever see no no no
no no no no no no no those guys fought
that way because that's who the fuck
they are right right yeah yeah yeah yeah
said no there's no dad nothing to do
with that
Jason night and I'm lobe off yeah yeah
yeah yeah you can't you can't claim
credit for uh Hinkler for Jason Knight
do anybody and our Lobo fuck out of here
they would fight that way in a fucking
Walmart parking lot yeah that's how
those guys would fight every time they
fight Jason Knight go both those dudes
are and what those dudes are so tough
Jason Knight has my favorite nickname
Nick Diaz yeah yeah bad motherfucker
yeah yeah he's a bad motherfucker that
but it was tough looking at their faces
man after the fight I was like man I
might have to rethink my position on
unbearable
look at their faces afterwards yeah I
mean that is crazy you know it's a
lifetime of cuts yeah all over the film
lookit is right under his nose like that
is crazy cut man is to stitch the fuck
up all over the place that is rough man
his whole face got lacerated I mean that
is a lot of cuts
yeah it's not that's more like a Muay
Thai fight and it really makes you think
but I can't that's got to be the most
brutal right more time yeah I believe so
muy Thai bare-knuckle would be like
would they call it less way uh-huh
they just they kind of like wrap the
hands up in a hand wrap yeah it's not
bare-knuckle but it's um
I think barren and bare knuckled moines
time would be the the hardest but to
think what my argument was always and
that's it still remains this that if
you're not gonna pad anything else like
you're not gonna pad the shins you're
not gonna bad the knees or the elbows
why you patting the knuckles you're just
giving people false sense of security in
terms of what is actually effective we
don't want we don't want to practice
something that doesn't really work if
you don't have gloves on right
I mean if every time you punch someone
you don't have gloves on your hand would
break right okay we clearly can't punch
people it's stupid you gotta use elbows
and knees and you're saying right so in
order to fight with your knuckles as
much as UFC fighters do you pat
everything you pad that you put wraps
you put padding over it boxing is like
it's a different world as soon as you
take gloves off yeah it's a different
world punches get in that you can't
block it's it has many more consequence
a lot more cuts but at least if now we
know what actually works all right
you're saying I wasn't thinking about it
from that point of view yeah that is
given people people are thinking that
yeah you're right like people think that
boxing well before I mean my everything
was the most effective way of doing
things yeah but then when you are MMA is
a whole different from the size of the
boxing glove no the techniques you can
do and what you can't do and what's
gonna work and what's not gonna work
yeah it's it's supposed to be the sport
of fighting and you basically brought it
down to a raw form but you're still
covering the knuckles and padding the
knuckles just because of perception and
see the problem with that guy this
bare-knuckle got box and Gandhi says
some stupid shit like that is that it
reinforces what people don't like about
combat sports what people don't like
about the idea of bare-knuckle boxing
that it's brutal it's just there for
chaos and right right right for action
we're here to see action that guys don't
think that about any man yeah
and and and I don't think that um I
don't think that MMA athletes I think
MMA athletes I think are the most
honorable and well behaved and you know
not because of fear anything because of
what the sport is